so welcome everybody and I'm glad to be
here and I'm glad that PI data is
happening in the Carolinas thanks to the
organizers that did a wonderful job here
the github repo for the tutorial you can
look it up afterwards or you can also
download it now if you want you will not
need it on the servers that you've been
given you'll be able to access it
directly so the URL for the github repo
is github.com /f d io n slash PI data
alrighty so just before we start how
many of you are considering themselves
data scientists ok how many of you are
I've built at least a linear regression
model ok so at least we'll be starting
with dad common ground maybe you have
not or maybe you've done web
applications maybe you haven't and
that's fine we'll get you up to speed on
we'll do that but as far as a Python and
doing web application this is not
something new at all so if anybody has a
copy of this Internet programming with
Python written by van Rossum and waters
and Alstom 1996
so yes Python and web applications is
something very mature right in fact if
you have any doubt as to what it means
1996 so to put things in perspective
that's 20 years 20 years to put things
in perspective visually how would you
have bought Star Wars at the store
probably on VHS tape or perhaps on
laserdisc right ok so there's been a
long time so it's mature don't worry
about it you'll be able to use it and
scale it however you need to scale it
and so tonight this morning I mean we'll
be able to present this tutorial to help
you go from zero to launching a web
application with a model and using flash
and so we'll start with Don you know QM
well no I actually I'm sorry just before
making sure that everybody was able to
access that screen you've received a
little paper yes okay very good
you don't have one if Don do you have an
extra number that's less okay so we spun
up to the room capacity so you can't
share because you'll step on each
other's toes and when you have the
password you login usually we'll get a
screen that looks like this and Don will
guide you from there will tell you if
you want to follow along you'll notice
that there's a PS directory and you can
open that we're gonna start with the
hello pie
so to start we're going to build on what
we already know so take a look at these
next couple of slides
this is pretty familiar to us right we
have a client in this case a browser
which is making a request which goes to
a server and the server sends back a
response
well pretty for me of that the key terms
of course are client and server requests
in response we start with the URL in the
browser and the main thing that I want
to point out to you is that there's a
particular scheme protocol HTTP which
we're using and of course the host is
where the web application lives and the
other important part is the path and
France flag gave me this nice little
yeah there we go
just have to remember to use it so the
great thing about a protocol is that it
allows us to communicate and we can
expect a client and the server to be
able to talk with each other when the
client makes a response the important
part of that is as we mentioned a moment
ago the path but it's also has to tell
something else to the server and that's
what kind of method to use so in this
case it's making a get request it's
familiar to everybody yeah great seems
shaking it's so of course when the
server gets that request and I'm not
used to standing still sorry when the
server gets that request it takes some
kind of action in this case it's
returning hello world pretty simple
right so we're gonna build our first web
app there's a we're gonna edit a new
file in the hello in the www boards last
tutorial directory now you have a choice
if you from I mean you would do bit or
notebook which I'm sure you are
you can either edit it in the notebook
or if you want to get a terminal and you
go over to new choose terminal using
this mouse
they work it and you can use them from
the command line if you're familiar with
a man or you can edit it in the or he
can go in the WWE everybody feel like
you're where you're supposed to be raise
your hand if you're not because Daniel
is available to walk around and Francois
is also so we're going to edit a new
file called hello pie again if you have
any trouble go ahead and flag down
friends for Daniel and we're building a
flask web application so the first thing
that we do is you're familiar with in
Python you're going to import some kind
of module so we're gonna import from
flask flask flask object and the very
next line is we're going to instantiate
our flask object and we're just going to
call it app for simplicity sake of
course you can name it whatever you want
the flask module takes the name I mean
flask applicant
either the the name dunder name which is
either the hello dot pie hello or main
if you're calling it from the command
line but you don't have to worry about
that actually
so everybody got that
look at me throw things at me something
again that's one of the great reasons
you can follow along with the PDF type
the next thing we want to do is we
actually want to define a function which
is going to return the simple string
hello world the great thing is when
you're using flask is it takes care of
building the response I mean you're
going to build the response but it takes
care of sending it back to the client in
an appropriate manner according to that
HTTP protocol so this is pretty simple
so far right
now the key thing is though how does how
do we tie this together this function
that's returning a simple string to that
path that we had earlier the forward
slash hello we actually have to add a
route what's called a route another name
for path and so we use the decorator I
don't know how many of you familiar with
a decorator but if you're not it's ok
you don't have to understand how your
car works in order to drive you just
have to know that you start it with the
@ symbol and the app dot route and
that's a decorator on this particular
function so it goes right above this
function it's so anytime our apple of
the client makes a request to the route
/hello or that path this function is
going to execute the final piece of the
puzzle that we need for our application
the way that we're running it here this
morning is the if dunder name construct
which you probably have seen before if
you've done much python programming and
the important point here is that you've
got the app dot run and so this is
what's gonna actually cause our web
developments or our development server
to run the pork is correct at 0 dot 0
dot 0 that's going to tell it to listen
all interfaces and we want this very
important keyword argument debug equals
true that way when you have some kind of
problem maybe it can't find a template
or we have some other kind of runtime
exceptions you'll actually get that
information a good question
on the server it's gonna listen to any
requests that are coming from externally
does that make sense any other questions
about that how many folks are actually
typing yeah great is the pace pretty
good okay fantastic
once you do that once you get that typed
in you're gonna need to go to the
terminal if you did if you're already
there
or if you didn't you can go back to the
joopa notebook and under that new menu
on the top right hand side choose a
terminal
I forgot to put slide in here from the
command line you're gonna have to change
directories to the www forward slash
tutorial how many of you from me over
the command line and know how to change
directories on there alright be sure and
help your neighbor to change directories
in the terminal to the www port slash
tutorial
do that
so once you're in the tutorial you can
CD CD to www
to toriel
I'm sorry cds sandbox /w the tutorial if
I could tied and then once you're there
you should see your hello dot PI and
from the command line you can type I
have here Python three space hello dot
PI that's going to actually calls the
development server that comes with flats
it's built into flask start running
so just briefly I think we had to assume
more fluency with Jupiter but basically
if you want to create your hello ducky Y
from Jupiter when you click on the
directory
ww then you can go file I mean new text
file rename it to hello dot py and then
you can start typing your code there
doesn't make sense
let me show here screen I go on ww you
text file fortunately I think we're
texting a little bit the Wi-Fi in here
so if anybody prefers to work on that
locally again you can pull the the
github repo on your local machine
assuming you have trigger and all these
tools there so it's thinking there you
go
file rename hello py and then you can
start typing away
as far as the get up its get up calm /f
d io n /pi data
so what we'll do also as we will review
a notebook with the linear regression
for those that are already familiar with
dad then you can take that time to catch
up and finish the Lowi right so after
you do the Python 3 hello dot pie
hopefully it tells you that the server
is listening and that it's running on
port 5000 and so then in your browser
you should be able to go to HTTP and for
the 0.020 you're gonna have to
substitute the IP address that's where
your jupiter notebook is running make
sense and then make sure you run it on
connect to port 5000 with that colon
5,000 and /hello
and surprise surprise what do you expect
to see there
francois hello dot world right I mean
hello comma world okay so hopefully you
liked it how many people had success
yeah now if you've not have had success
we've had several different issues like
the browser insisting upon putting www
in front of your address don't know
what's up with that so we're gonna
continue in the now what do we notice
about that response right it was just a
simple to returning a string that's a
static response but of course when we're
building web applications we're more
interested in something a little
different so take a look at this next
one and what you notice is that
something different is happening right
we've added something to the path a name
and then instead of just getting back
hello world now we're getting back hello
sue hello Don hello honor so it's a
dynamic response right and that's what
we want to be able to build when we're
doing web applications in order to do
that one of the things that you very
often want
do when you're when you have a website
and you have a particularly canned feel
for example to that website you have a
lot of the HTML that's going to stay the
same from page to page to page right so
what we want to be able to do then is we
want to be able to template just like if
you were sending a letter to colleagues
what you want to personalize it and have
it you know dear and the colleagues name
there even though all the rest of the
letter is the same you want to customize
it you might make what a template so for
templating when you're using gin flask
we use ginger too so we have a notebook
if you'll go to the notebooks directory
ginger to ipython notebook
if you click on the netbooks and you can
follow along in this notebook
it's the Jinja to write
Jinja 2 is separate a separate project
from flask but flask makes great use of
it and all that simplifies a number of
things for you when you're using Jinja 2
so anyway as I was saying it's the
templating engine all you have to do is
have some simple text files which have
some special Jinja 2 syntax and the
first thing as I mentioned when you were
sending that letter of the colleague and
you wanted to insert the name so the
first thing you don't have to have your
template are variables and the variables
look just like this let's go full screen
here and they start with the braces and
then you'll have a variable name and
then close braces and from the Jinja -
oh sorry to make this simple just be
able to demonstrate what's happening
without running it in a web application
I'm actually just going to import the
template this is not the way that you
would you don't have to worry about this
when you're running it from your web
application but I just want to be able
to highlight the template that we're
building and you can see the hello and
the braces and our variable we decided
to call it name the braces aren't part
of your output but then you can use just
your normal Python right I've got a list
of names here we're gonna iterate over
those names and then I'm gonna print
that and what happens shocking it's it's
you're gonna be surprised no wait you're
not surprised that's exactly what you
expected right so very simple concept
but allows you to do powerful things now
the thing about Jinja 2 is it also gives
you some control structures which allow
you to have some logic in your templates
and as the template designer this is
very important especially if you're
building HTML and you want say list for
example you don't want to type list
after you know Li after Li after Li tags
instead you want to allow the the
instead you want to allow the template
engine to do that for you and so we have
these statements they're very simple
syntax again it starts with a bracelet %
and again as I mentioned we have control
structures in Jinja too so we're going
to cover just a few of those the if
condition and you might do something
you're going to execute a block of code
in here just like you would the block of
code and if conditional and Python and
then very importantly it has the NDF so
that you can tell where that control
block ends so I have another template
here and this time we're gonna have an
if conditional if there's a name we're
gonna print that name otherwise we're
just going to default to the hello world
I see some heads shaking makes makes
good sense fantastic I'm gonna execute
that so if I print that template
rendering the name guest you're gonna be
shocked again oh no you're not of course
I wish it would on the screen hello
guest if I template if I render that
template without passing the keyword
argument to it it simply prints hello
world any questions about that it's
pretty straightforward right
it also has Jinja 2 also has for
structure and again a very simple
example you're iterating over names now
this time what we've done differently
here before we were letting the Python
iterate correct relating the Python repo
this time we're gonna actually let the
template engine loop over the name so
instead of passing at a single name each
time we're gonna pass it a list of names
you see the name equal names and we're
gonna get our output hello sue alright
all very straight
for word the final thing that I want to
highlight for you Jinja to does have
some other constructs but these are the
ones that you're going to use day in and
day out and this one is the block name
and the end block control structure what
this allows us to do in Jinja 2 is
inherit remember the whole point of a
template is to be able to have some
boilerplate code and a parent for
example and then in the child template
you're gonna overwrite a section of
you're gonna fill in excuse me you're
gonna fill in a section of the parent
template I mean if you've used
templating and Microsoft Word or you
know some other kind of few people so
we're gonna build our first template now
the great thing is this time you have an
existing file so if you'll go to the www
for slash tutorial forward slash
templates directory there you'll find a
layout dot HTML this is going to be our
parent template and inside of that
template and many of you're familiar
with HTML yeah pretty much everybody
right I mean if you've written HTML yeah
I'm sorry
so the we're not going to go over the
HTML it's pretty standard stuff right
but this is the stuff that we want to
have included in every page so instead
the main thing that I want to highlight
for you is the block control structure
that we had a moment ago so in Jinja two
renders our child template the child
template is going to connect and fill in
this part the block main so this is the
part that you need to add to the layout
dot HTML the block main and the end
block you'll notice that main here is
what I called it you choose the name
that you want to reference so some
people choose content body any number of
things that make sense for you and
that's important because as you'll
notice I have another block up here for
title as I simply named it two different
names so that in the child template you
can reference
which space you're trying to feel now
there's also a child template their
child dot HTML
and in that template we already have
some other Jinja to which hey this looks
familiar we'd had this just a moment ago
right it's exactly the same and we have
to do two things here right any guesses
what the two things are this is all we
have right now in this template what we
use in the parent template is that the
okay yeah we're gonna eventually need a
list of names for this but think about
we were just looking at our parent
template and what did we add to our
parent template yeah well one second on
that yeah we have to have the block and
then gentleman in the back also remind
me to give you a prize later the
gentleman in the back also said that we
need to inherit from our from our
templates so those are the two things
we're going to add to this file we need
to add the extends and that's what tells
Jinja to hey this one this child
template is a child template of our
layout dot HTML and then the other thing
is that we want to over we want to fill
in all of this code in the parent
template block main yeah
yeah if you can pull up that PD and
remember if you can pull up the PDF
maybe you can split windows so you can
have the PDF on the right side and and
the child out HTML on the left side so
anyway we've tied our jet child HTML our
child template to our parent template
we've filled in part of the block one of
the blocks in the parent so now we have
to be able to use those templates right
so there's an existing file inherit PI
inherit PI and the WWE tutorial
directory that's the parent of the
templates directory and this applet this
simple application looks very much like
the first one that we did our static
application but this time we're making
it more dynamic so the first thing that
we'll notice is we've added a new
function which we're importing and
that's the render template and then
finally instead of returning our static
stream like we did earlier we're
returning that child template the great
thing about flask when you're using it
with Jinja too is that it knows where
the templates are it has some a couple
of different rules but basically the way
that we're running it it knows that it
can find this template in a templates
directory which sits alongside our
inherit dot pi by so if you add those
couple of lines to inherit PI render
template and the render template
function call child dot HTML and that's
what it's going to do
after you add those you're gonna have to
go back to your terminal and if your
other flasks web application is still
running the original and you'll just hit
control-c a couple of times and that's
going to kill it and then you'll do
Python 3 and inherit PI and you probably
can't see that something's gonna put it
back up here Python 3 inherit dot pi Oh
silly me I forgot something so what we
did is that we forgot to pass a name in
right so we're gonna do one additional
thing we need to add a new route so now
we have two routes to which this
function will respond flasks will call
our function whenever the client makes a
request to either of these routes and
you'll notice we've added a keyword
argument to our function and we've also
added keyword argument to the render
template so let's talk for just a moment
about the route we're going to notice is
that we have something special here this
is the flask syntax for adding a
variable to the path so simply put the
angled brackets around the name the
variable name and so when the client
calls that name with a name like hello
sue it's going to pass sue as the value
for the key name to the function hello
now the awesome thing is about a flask
web application is it's just Python so
here when we pass name we can capitalize
it to straight out of the standard
library and it's gonna capitalize that
name for us and pass it to the template
as the name and that's the name that we
used in our template you buddy have
questions about that
and then if you go back to the command
line and type Python 3 in here it dot pi
hopefully it all works yes and you can
visit the site and put ever whatever you
want for me and again it needs to be on
port 5,000 and you substitute your the
domain name for your 0.020 for your
jupiter notebook these are very simple
applications but they demonstrate the
various types of templating and control
structures and the routes that you need
in order to build a much more
complicated application any questions so
far
and now francois is not in the room
there he is and it's my turn to walk
around so flag me down
all righty so I think possibly in the
few cases where we had issues there were
two individuals on the same machines or
each other each writing over each
other's changes I'm sorry about that
lesson for the future give everybody a
super complicated password that can be
shared or something like that so all
righty so if we look at the notebook
here so this is more familiar you'll
you'll feel you know I think we we
pushed your comfort zone quite a bit
here for the first part but if you're a
data scientist notebooks is an
environment you're familiar with so if
we go under notebooks house valuation by
data dot capital notebook is the font
size good enough or I should bump this a
little bit like this better
yes no yes it is old dim yeah let's see
all right better enough okay so you're
probably used to importing things such
as pandas numpy things like that we will
first
well we're condensing something that
would have taken a lot longer where you
are tasked with getting data in this
case we just go and directly read it
from a get up content here and we end up
with house prices the price column is
various prices now as you see the those
prices don't be surprised by them this
is Seattle so yes you could buy tree
houses in North Carolina for the average
price of the house in Seattle
so if we look at some preliminary data
wrangling or munging that we'll do we'll
just add a renovated indicator will drop
the date and we have 21,000 records here
with 21 features so that's a lot of
features we probably wouldn't use all of
them but we look at some of the feature
I would think that square-foot square
footage would be a good indicator of
price what we're trying to build is a
model that will given some features will
give us a an estimate of the house price
that we could expect to pay or to sell
it for so the first thing I do and
tomorrow if he attend stem graphic
you'll be able to learn a little bit
more about stem and leaf plots in a
graphical way but if not let's just look
at the distribution of these 21,000 data
points in see did I not around the first
line yes
there you go I think again pushing the
network a little bit so as we look at
this
it starts at 75,000 actually I got a
pointer too so $75,000 all the way to
seven point seven million dollars that's
our data set heavy here in the three
hundred to four hundred thousand dollars
and the median is actually at around 450
right here so that gives us a little bit
of a an idea of what we're dealing with
if so if we look at pair plots with the
Seaborn
I'm sure you've used those we'll compare
the price and a square foot living and
the condition condition of the house
should matter right and a lot the square
footage of the lot so look at the
resulting plots we see so first of all
price and square footage right here we
see there's a at the lower end yes it's
a good representation but as we go
further do larger and larger square
footage there's a lot of variation so
yeah I will use that but caveat it does
vary quite a bit so it'll be a good
model for lower square footage and lower
prices but maybe not so much for higher
prices and higher square footage and so
if we continue here we'll look at so
again the square foot square footage
this what I was explaining we'll look at
latitude and longitude because location
location location in real estate right
is important and sure enough we see that
there's a peak right about here
for the latitude and if we look at the
longitude there's a peak here which
happened to be probably downtown Seattle
right so if we convert that to distance
from the center
which I already calculated that so we
wouldn't waste our time here we end up
with latitude and longitude from Center
D Delta right so if we plot this we'll
be able to see
sure enough it's not linear right I mean
the closer you are to downtown you know
but for the sake of this exercise we're
sticking with just the simple
relationship here and so for I I also
want a data frame without the price for
my model linear regression from
scikit-learn
along wit so here's what I'm doing I
could have used train test split and if
you go further in day in the notebook
you'll see that I'm using that for the
more advanced model but here I'm just
simply skipping over every other element
of my data frame so for my training set
and from a linear regression what do we
get no all right we get an intercept and
coefficients right and so if we were to
look at the equation that we would
represent this linear mall wit is
something like linear intercept plus the
first coefficient times the square
footage times the on a plus the second
coefficient times the condition because
I trained on right above on square
footage in condition I wanted something
simple right here but how do I use this
in a web application if I were to just
take this these tree lines although here
I'm getting a result here's the takeaway
if you're building something for a web
application it has to work stand alone
and what I mean by that if I create a
new I Python
and I pasted this is it gonna work no
why is that because I don't have my
linear regression model and so since
this is a very simple model what I could
do is just simply use the actual values
right so I could do something like let's
go back to our our intercept is this
number so we'll define a function we'll
define a function called ballpark
estimator it's a very simple estimator
that will take square footage in
condition and we could even put our
default value on it which are the actual
average which I noted here from the
panda's data frame that we add earlier
the describe function so we can just
pass as a default 2080 square feet
that's the average
and so we define the function that way
it is reusable so you're used to running
a ipython notebook from beginning to DM
here we're having to think about this is
going to be deployed on a web
application so this is what the
refactoring that needs to happen or even
better you always write your code like
this then you don't have to refactor it
in this case because it's a simple model
I will do this return the intercept plus
first coefficient we'll just copy and
paste of course this would not be a good
solution if we were training on multiple
data sets different cities or training
that every week so and so forth that'd
be kind of painful to have we probably
won't have time but in this notebook
also you'll see how to do with a more
advanced model or the same model by
exporting
linear regression model to disc
persisting it and then reloading it when
you need it on your web application
everybody following yes okay
the second coefficient and let's test
this by calling ballpark estimator and
let's do a square footage of two
thousand alrighty so we got for the
average value earlier we had gotten 541
but just by dropping eighty square feet
we're down to five hundred and eighteen
thousand which is still a good amount of
money so again now that I have this I
could easily take this go into a
different notebook this is the right way
to test right because no no I I know I
don't have any other variables or
anything like that this is fresh it
worked now I could go and take that and
put it into my notebook were you going
to demo that dong or
so we'll be a little brief on our
presentation because else we'll run out
of time but so we have a model we got a
function as a result of that so now
we're gonna introduce you to a couple of
new things we're gonna edit real estate
pie and the www for its last tutorial
directory which will allow us to build
another yeah if you still have that
other application running in the
terminal you can just ctrl C to kill
that here here's the ballpark estimator
that Francois just showed you a moment
ago from the notebook so you could
really copy and paste we're gonna add
that into our real estate pie anywhere
you like pretty much now a couple of the
things that I want to point out to you
though that we've added to this real
estate pie we already have our flask
object and our render template function
now we have a new object called request
now as you might guess request is
available whenever the client makes a
request it's very simple
however in Python this is a special
object it's a global object and we're
not going to go into what that means
right at the moment but the important
thing for you to know is that wait a
minute if we're gonna be interacting
with a user and we're gonna get them to
enter things like square footage and
conditions so that we can then return
that value we're gonna need to have a
webform right and so the request object
has a form object which then you can
actually get the values out of it by
simply using the keys from your form in
this case square foot and condition so
one of the highlight that the other
thing that we need to remember is an
HTTP there are different methods we've
been using the get all along but now
when you introduce
forms you can also use the post method
so now you have to be explicit in your
route decorator and you actually have to
list out the methods for which this
function will get called by default it
listens forgets so that's why we didn't
have to add it the first time but once
you start getting more complicated
you'll need to add a list of methods
that your function supports there are
other HTTP methods but we're not going
to need those for the purposes of this
and then all we need to do in our online
will should be line 9 I believe
depending on how you're counting
if the request dot method is equal to a
post then we know that we're that the
client has issued a so the important
thing that we need to think about now
that's all we need to add to our real
estate dot PI for it to connect to the
form but now we actually need a form
right we're not going to go very much
over the form except to notice that it's
using the post method and then it has
some inputs one of them is called square
feet that's what corresponds to that
request stop form square feet of course
call and then we also have a condition
which is a select it's just going to be
a drop-down with the condition and then
if you run Python 3 real estate I after
adding your function then you should get
the form and be able to input yeah let
me show the completed sorry that's great
yeah where do you have it Thanks
so just so we can glance so you can see
the completed file where we added the
request we also added our methods to the
route decorator this is listening on the
route and we also passed in and just
like before we were passing a name to
our function now we're passing in square
foot and condition we check if the
request stop method is post then we're
going to get those values from the form
and then we're gonna use our ballpark
estimate or passing those to the
function and then when it returns it
either way we render a template so the
first time that this gets called is when
the client makes a get request and then
all that will happen is is it will
render this blank form and then the next
time that it gets called with the post
request it will actually execute that
conditional block if and fill in those
values so this is just an expanded
version of what we were doing earlier
the only difference now is that we've
added the request object so that we can
actually find out things about the
requests that the client is making
of course we still have our if dunder
name at the bottom any questions about
what's happening here and how we've tied
this to our forum a particularly
quizzical looks so I'll take that as a
good sign of course you can visit it at
substituting your domain name at IP
address domain name for 0.020 and 4,000
at the root path so later on when you
have some time free time between
sessions or whatever or the end of the
day you're bored at this social we have
a couple of extra files in there that
you can go and follow the instructions
inside and get a little more practice
back to francois again it's possible
that not every single file is actually
on the github repo yet I think we've
done a lot of this stuff it was dark
outside and we were a little tired I
think
however today we'll make sure that all
the missing files are uploaded if you're
missing any of the like demos or
examples and stuff like that so if we go
back to our notebook we just build our
estimator and I'll just briefly go
through here and if we scored this our
CB score here is actually 0.48 this is
good enough for a ballpark estimator of
course we could do better if you're no
doubt familiar with the RFP the
recursive feature elimination of
scikit-learn
so you could run that and say oh okay
let's see what are those top six
features that I could use here and all
of all the columns it actually
decided the RF esupport and I passed
that to the column name so I could see
what they are so it's going to be square
foot living which is the number one we
had selected waterfront we had condition
but here it says waterfront and
obviously this would impact tremendously
if you're in front of the beach versus
you know if you have the view of a brick
wall or something like that square
footage above square footage basement
latitude from Center longitude from
Center which is good because we kind of
have the feeling that location would be
important so what we could do here so
we'll do a training and test split with
train test split train our model we have
a model but and in fact we can print
o-67
so it would be a bit better however we
do have to pass a lot more to our
function and our function is going to be
a little more complicated but also I
just wanted to take a moment to note
here that what you might want to do is a
pan to the model we just built so LR
what did I just do No so LR dot let's
say that we want to save that score so
we could add an attribute called CV
equal LR score next test Y test anybody
has a guess as to why I would save the
score with my model if I'm going to
deploy dad and maybe true an automation
system and I have a criteria of a
minimum score that I want to use I could
automatically deploy new changes that
are pushed to get out for example pulls
it from github it runs or it looks at
the model that being saved through the
automation or maybe it's trained only
once and you
pushing just a train model well the
Train model by itself doesn't tell you
anything right I mean you don't know
when it was trained you don't know how
good it is or anything like that but if
I do this and actually let's go further
and do LR that version it's random
attributes I mean you can name them
whatever you want
pretty much let's do a date/time dot
today and so now I've saved the moment
at which it was trained and the CV score
within my model how would we call or how
do we well we need to save it at this
point right because this is not
available outside so how would I save it
let's import from scikit-learn externals
job lid from SK learn external import
second spell job
and what job live now I can do job lived
um my linear regression model that I
just trained along with the extra extra
attributes and saved that to a folder
called Train malls lrp KL and what it
did
it saved my train model along with the
numpy data that's associated with it
into that train model folder and so I
could have something me open a terminal
now see
house valuation so I got my train models
that I just created here and I wrote a
little quick script this would be about
as simple as it would get for an actual
deployment script right where you just
copy if you've pickled data also you
would do the same but the Train model
would be copied over so if I run this
it's actually copied over to my 3w
directory so this could be actually a
SCP or something that's controlled by an
automation or continuous integration
continuous deployment system but again
it could also instead of joint doing a
copy or something like that it could
actually load the model with job Lib
check the CV score check the date and if
the date is a wonky maybe it's a year
ago maybe it's a little say no no I
can't load this this is too old or the
CV score is 0.01 nevermind I don't want
that so on and so forth so you can
actually add other attributes that fit
the bill for you for your deployment
make sense everybody all right and so if
I were to let's go back to our know look
how to call it so the bad thing is we
have six features that we need a good
thing is that even though some of them
are kind of complicated one is a
geolocation and if we are going to build
a form who knows they're ICBM
coordinates or the lat/long where they
live or the house that they want to buy
nobody right so for from a user
experience you will want to have an
input of the address and then take the
address and get the latitude and
longitude fortunately there's something
called nominate 'm which is part of
OpenStreetMap that you can
use and actually it's one of the geo
coders there's other geo coders I'm sure
that there are people in the room that
have their own solution that the company
do work that you can use that it doesn't
matter geo PI supports many geo coder so
we'll load the geo coder x' right here
so our better estimator we looked at
from a user experience they will have to
tell us the square footage still maybe a
checkbox for waterfront are you in front
of the beach or whatever below the grade
square footage if they give us the below
grade square footage then we already
have the total square footage we can
calculate also the above grade pretty
simple
and finally the address thanks to
nominate them we'll get the latitude and
longitude but we also want really the
latitude longitude offset from the
center we had calculated again this is
specific to Seattle so you probably
would want and it's normal to actually
build a model per large city like that
versus perhaps in peripheral areas
you'll see that the same model holds
across a much wider area much greater
area so it doesn't make sense here so if
we run this let's see if it does work
again we define a function we spent some
time in the notebook making sure it
works and you know print better
estimator so I actually I put a random
address 101 Main Street it couldn't
figure it out quite it said well maybe
you're saying wanting 15th Avenue
Northwest probably not quite right but
if will will actually show you the
running application and we'll try to put
an address that actually exists in
Seattle and see what happens but that's
on your rate notice that the same this
is 2,000 square feet and earlier we ran
and we got 518 thousand or something
like that
650 mm just because
this is in Seattle proper versus in
outside of Seattle in peripheral areas
so the average we see that we are much
higher than average here and the last
piece I wanted to touch on beside
creating more advanced models and again
to export it would be as we saw fairly
simple we just use this year right and
so we can use it in our better estimator
and this is the line the one line that
calls that loads the model back into the
estimator and the last line estimates it
with the LR predict and that should be
familiar for those that are using
scikit-learn and linear regression or
linear regression in general in facts
visualization you're probably using
maybe matplotlib or one of the seventeen
other leading packages under Python and
if you want to know what they are you
can go to the github repo on the readme
there's a bunch of links to other
libraries visualization library however
this would be probably how I would look
at this maybe doing the residuals on
both my training and my test set the
test set is in blue and it's plotted
second so I can see if they are
overlapping or if they're very different
might vary some questions also for it
and you can see this is not that great
right I mean actually we're going here
the variation is not symmetrical it is
so there's a lot of a heteroscedasticity
going on here but still it looks like
it'd be usable in the middle
right I mean again we only are using six
features and we just went with a
straight linear relationship I mean we
could go a lot more complex but for this
exercise I think that's sufficient how
do you get this visualization maybe your
boss walks in he says oh this looks
pretty I want to show that in the
boardroom okay I'll send you a
PowerPoint no no I want to it's got to
be on our commercial external accessible
website and it's something I want to
demo to customers - are you sure yeah
yeah yeah all right so how do we do that
we do that by using MP LD tree so that's
going to limit the amount of work we
have to do here I don't think we had
imported it here now we end I'll bring
it up
so while it's bringing it up MP LD tree
allows us to use matplotlib or even
Seaborn and publish that to the web as
SVG but it actually as a function that
returns HTML that's ready to integrate
with your template and so the way we
would do that we don't just import
matplotlib pipe lettuce
PLT once we have actually installed with
pip install MP LD tree we are doing this
here so if I go back I can go down
replace this so that would be basically
it's not a big change right I mean I'm
just adding comma and PLD tree and the
other thing I will want to do if I am
mixed exposing if I am putting death on
a web page if I can find
okay this time we also have to specify
the render okay so what's the default
render with matplotlib it uses the X
server on Linux or Mac system or
actually one graphical system that has
to be up and running we don't have that
on web server the web server is actually
instantiated from a process I mean if
you're in production probably true
something like supervisor or something
like that so we don't have access to
that back hand and so what we do is use
an alternate back-end that will work
with the web and that's AGG so so in the
web application I'm bringing up again
because due to time we won't have time
to actually type this stuff so again
adding that at the beginning of my web
application can you see that from the
back yeah okay so basically importing
matplotlib saying use a GG and then
import the PI plot as p LT n n p LD tree
now if I go to my new method that I've
added my new function an admin function
with the metrics so now because my plot
mm-hmm sorry because my plot actually
use data from the test and train set
right I mean normally you would have
that you wouldn't publish that you
wouldn't use that into but your boss
said yeah do it so are you doing it
right so what I am doing here is simply
just creating another folder called data
and I will pickle a truther job live
again the well I had done that on the
notebook itself and now I would have it
available here as X test y test and X
train and a white train so now I can
actually run my plot scatter for my test
and train set but again normally this is
not a usual scenario but this is a worst
case scenario I'm just showing you you
can handle even that worst case scenario
which is I need every single data point
from the original data frame or actually
from the Train model and the test and
train in this case and the last piece as
I'm using this NP LD tree fig to HTML
and I'm getting to figure itself from
the axe that's returned from the plot
call why am i doing that well because I
need HTML and not the PNG and I'll need
a PDF
I want something interactive although I
could have used a PNG or PDF and in this
case then it becomes a static
server you're just basically showing
this exact same document every time here
it would actually change based on you
know if the data behind it changes then
the graphs will change so that metric
page always gets refreshed from if you
have a deployment of a model every night
and then every following morning you can
go and check Oh what does it look like
and in fact what I'm doing here with
metrics of HTML it's in template let's
open it
so only hmm let's make it a little bit
bigger so we're extending the layout
again we're defining a block and in this
block main I will have current model
version is the variable l r dot version
remember I said we should probably have
the date in there so we know when this
model was trained wit a CV score of LR
CV so again that comes in handy so at
least I can refer to these values here
and then I insert my date of this now
here I put safe telling Jinja that it's
okay to not touch the HTML that's being
spit out else it'll try to escape it
it'll make it in such a way that it will
not render in your web browser so that's
super important you're saying no I know
what I'm doing this is actual SVG HTML
it's it's cool do it and basically it
will do it and how about a demo then
perhaps we can run this whole thing and
see what do we have if I can find my
running terminal this one
so real-estate tree is the one that has
both the advanced model and the the
metrics page
oh no I want to do an HTTP so so this
would be deform for the more advanced
model where we could put an address I
did say we'd check something out right
so let's go to Google Maps here and see
if we can't find something Seattle
how about I don't know the university
you know you see what we can find
I'll just grab a random address here
okay for for a one Terry Avenue and copy
dad put that in the forum and let's say
again mm fortunately because I have a
default and I waterfront as a checkbox
and I am pretty sure this was not a
waterfront I don't have to check that
I won't even specify the square foot
feet bill oh great I'll just see what
happens here so I submit it will call
nominate him and should come back oh not
good so I think we timed out the ER I'm
sorry no I will default to one says
don't panic but I'm panicking it's
alright yeah and I don't see maybe we
should have no mm yeah that should have
worked let's try it again no yeah it
probably timed out so we would have had
to actually handle the time out of the
query to nominate him and it's possible
that I've reached my limit for today too
Wow okay this is an even higher seven
hundred and twenty nine thousand and the
last thing we did was adding this
metrics page right so the metrics page
what it does have is first of all it
renders what it can right away and then
the SVG is actually that's 21,000
data points so if you actually want to
do visualizations with that many data
point I'd probably suggest maybe also
looking at other options that instead of
using SVG for apps you want to use
something like the canvas or WebGL and
there's different
libraries that will handle that in fact
today I think there's a tutorial on
bouquet that will handle exactly that so
you'll want to check that out and so
here because it's a interactive forum I
can actually go and click on the zoom
icon zoom in and again at 21,000 data
point it's a little sluggish but it'll
get there eventually there so again with
the minimum effort we went from a
Jupiter notebook into an actual
application that's up and running that
has an advanced model that has a form
that has metrics and visualizations that
you can share of course this is just the
beginning you might say like no no wait
this is this is good enough ship it
right no unfortunately not
there's security aspects that need to be
handled there's all kinds of other stuff
so you'll want to go back to our PI data
get up repo FD on slash PI data and look
at not just the basics and the machine
learning which you probably know already
individualization which you probably
know already the further reading there's
a ton of the lists like the list of
lists or the awesome flask lists you
will want to look at that because it
goes and talks about tutorials courses
books slides videos and all kinds of
other fun stuff including adding an
admin tool and adding security because
you don't want to ship stuff without
passwords and things like that admin
tools and things like so you'll have to
do a lot of reading on that
however I'll plug in another tool that I
found very useful it's called cookie
cutter if you've never used this
actually I use it to generate even scrip
for deployment to the cloud it's
basically a template so let's say you've
done your application once you're like
okay this is what I want to reuse again
and again I just want to plug in a few
variables so you can use cookie cutter
to do that and it'll generate a new
project every time there's cookie cutter
flag
ask flash - and flask foundation that
you can look on get up and you'll be
able to generate these application very
quickly and that is pretty much it
unless you have questions anybody ask
questions we do have how many like a
minute so we have five minutes actually
so no all right everybody you you have
five minute more to go in and have
snacks and appreciate your time thank
you